Speaker 1: OK, I want to talk next about
the party that claims to support our police. We
must never defund. We must never restrict. We
must never limit the techniques and tools
and tactics that police are able to use.
And yet they have been persistently and
consistently attacking the officers that were
there trying to defend the Capitol on January
6th of this year, the day of the Trump riots.
We're going to look at a clip today of Newsmax
host Greg Kelly calling the police officers who
testified at those hearings about the Trump riots
quote crisis actors. Now we we even have to talk
about that term crisis actors, crisis actors is
a term that in sort of. General, popular culture,
to the extent that it's a term people are even
familiar with was kind of popularized by extreme
conspiracy theorists like Alex Jones. I think
my first introduction to the term crisis actor
was when Alex Jones alleged that the parents
of the victims of the shooting at Sandy Hook
in Newtown, Connecticut, Newton Newtown. I always
forget how it's spelled and pronounced opposite
under Barack Obama, that they were crisis actors.
They weren't really the parents of the victims,
or there weren't really victims, and
these were whatever. That's my first real
exposure to the term crisis actors. And in this
segment, Greg Kelly uses the term to refer to
the police officers. Now remember Greg Kelly
and Republicans. They support the police and
all of that stuff. OK, let's take a listen.
Speaker 2: As for Trump, you know where he
was on January six? He gave that speech. I always
said he had a great alibi. I mean, no one is not
at the Capitol and number two. He specifically
told people to keep it peaceful, right? I know
that everyone here will soon be marching
over to the Capitol building to peacefully
and patriotically make your voices heard.
Speaker 1: Now, anybody who doesn't realize
Trump's talking in code to his followers, you've
got to understand the way dog whistles work,
but that's not even the focus of this segment.
Speaker 2: All right. So I'm not a lawyer,
but here's what I would do. We know I would print
off a picture of those four police officers at the
hearing a couple of months ago. These guys,
Speaker 1: these some people call them
Speaker 2: crisis actors. I think
that was a pretty apt description.
Speaker 1: Totally unprofessional.
Speaker 2: This is a law enforcement, more than a
political question about Jan. six, in my opinion,
a security matter. But I would not want to
Speaker 1: go in front of this phony baloney
committee and buy phony baloney. I mean,
this is phony baloney. Think about what you have
to believe in order to follow these people in any
real way. Right. The world is just full of crisis
actors and a false flags the Sandy Hook shooting
years ago. They say that was a false flag with
crisis actors. The impetus was to take people's
guns, which, by the way, it didn't happen. Record
gun sales weren't even able to pass universal
background checks after Sandy Hook, the Jan. six
riots that was a false flag by antifa or liberals
to make Trumpists look bad. But it was also
peaceful. Trumpists that conflicts. They don't
care. It was just it was a false flag. The police
officers who were hurt, scared, abused. They are
crisis actors also to make Trumpists look bad. But
consider what that even means. Crisis actor The
police officers were crisis actors. Does that mean
they're not really police officers or they are,
but they're lying about what happened or the
videos depicting what happened were staged? Like,
What does it even mean to say that the police
officers are crisis actors? It doesn't matter.
The government that supposedly is in charge really
isn't in charge as the basis for a lot of this.
We talked about that shadow government conspiracy
yesterday. So it's a kind of package of conspiracy
theories. Sometimes it's called deep state.
Sometimes it's trilateral commission, Illuminati,
the Bilderberg, the Jews, the Vatican, whoever.
They're really in charge, not the president and
the vice president and the normal centers of
power. Once you buy into that general idea,
it's very easy to be convinced or tricked into
believing that the so-called police officers
were crisis actors. They were hired. It was staged
in some way, shape or form. And what's kind of
notable about this is they don't even realize
that they are playing right into the propaganda
of foreign nations when they promote this stuff,
including Russia's disinformation campaigns.
The centers of this type of conspiracy in the
U.S. right now are right wing evangelicals.
Love and spread this stuff. Older white
Republicans love and spread this stuff,
authoritarians just kind of like fascist dictator,
wannabe authoritarian types. Right wing media like
Fox, Newsmax own, although there are some of the
Republicans who don't subscribe to this stuff.
But this is exactly the type of stuff that Russia
works to spread. The U.S. isn't really in control.
The U.S. is being controlled by someone else.
You can't trust American democracy. Democracy
has failed. You can't trust the election
results. This is the Putin Russia game.
They don't even realize that they're playing right
into it. Out of one side of their mouth, they say
Russiagate. It was fake. It was trumped
up. It was Rachel Maddow and whoever.
But at the same time, they're spreading the exact
stuff that the Russian disinformation propaganda
campaigns want to spread. And if there's really
a crisis actor, isn't it the people on Newsmax
pretending to be news people like, that's
really the acting that's going on. And sadly,
it's tricking a lot of people. A lot of people are
falling for it, and they're not even questioning
it in any serious way. So this is the latest now.
The police officers who they claim to support.
Are the crisis actors and then just look as a
final point, which it must be made any time we
talk about right wing conspiracies, about either
the military or the police, law enforcement,
et cetera, they have the stated principle that
they support the troops and they support the
police, et cetera. It's not really a principle
they abide by. They abandon it as soon as it's
inconvenient to support the police or support the
troops. In this case, if they support the police,
they're supporting these officers. Saying it
was a Trumpist violent madhouse doesn't work.
So the principal gets abandoned immediately.
They don't actually care about the principles.